the jurgen experience um but we're
almost dead let's be honest
i mean how much time we got left if
everything goes great no no we're gonna
live forever we're gonna we're gonna
have that pill that they're gonna
that's gonna be announced next week that
might be the worst thing that could
happen like you might want to go
you know quietly in your sleep rather
than
live for 500 years and see the the
horrors that humanity
turns into that too and i don't want to
like if my body breaks down i'm not i'm
so physical i love
i love doing my stuff i i don't think
i'd be one of those
people like you know what his mind is so
sharp though
it's like well [ __ ] that's great
meanwhile the guy can't [ __ ] walk
yeah you can't you know it's like i want
to be able to do my my thang
yes yes listen i want a sharp mind let's
let's
for sure stipulate that but what do you
what do you do to maintain yourself what
do you do to keep
the machine working well the number one
thing was you know i i stopped drinking
years and years and years ago you know
how many years 30 oh so you got way
ahead of the game
so i'm way ahead i'm way ahead so i
don't do any of that um
wow that's that's a that's a lot of
discipline
it's well but it's not though because
the minute you realize your discipline
has nothing to do with it that's the
only way you can do it
oh okay because the whole point is like
i can't i
i can't if if i had if i had one
let's say you broke out that because i
was like beer beer was good well there
it is where you got there
whiskey was never my thing i'd be okay
if it were tequila that'd be a different
thing
if you if you and also it was the 80s so
if you had a kamikaze
remember those drinks yeah i do remember
those yeah um
like it would it would go
then i'd be like you know what would be
really good to get would be some
coke that would be great to balance it
out you just balance out and you know
that that
no big deal no big deal it's good for
you it's a rock star coke that's tough
that's what i'm saying it's not even bad
for you mick jagger does it
okay look at he's wretched he's fine
look at keith richards look at jack
nicholson look at i mean these guys are
doing this
they're the biggest stars in the world
nicholson is fat too how big how bad
could it be
how bad could it be it's good for your
memory probably
and it's really good if you want to talk
a lot it and and successful people do it
a lot of successful people do it and
it's not addicting
no they just enjoy it yes so that was
that was what we thought you know that's
what you know that's
is the gordon gekko era and then
and then the hounds of hell will be
released
once i got that good little concoction
going
that good little mixie mixer son well it
had to be hard
to be a young really famous
really good looking guy during the age
of no
internet and you know the world was a
wild place i mean you were really famous
in the 80s
i wouldn't i wouldn't trade it for
anything i mean
you know all of the look all the
mistakes that i made all the things that
i learned
got me to where i am today and i could
not be happier and i needed i needed
some [ __ ] comeuppance and i needed
some of that
humbling and stuff on the other side of
it is like
what's the point of being [ __ ] famous
today
really i don't know if there's nothing
i know right i i don't know i mean
forget
the lack of privacy the lack of like
crazy fun which you can't have
right um everybody's lying in weight
i saw an article written about leonardo
dicaprio and it was
just about how he dates young girls and
how gross it is
that he's dating in girls 25 like 25's a
woman you
[ __ ] right what is wrong he's a
good-looking man he's
wealthy and happy and successful oh my
god he dates someone who's young and
vibrant
there must be something wrong with him
meanwhile if a woman does it
nobody gives a [ __ ] they celebrate her
you go
kate beckinsdale you go take those 21
year olds down that's right
rope them wrangle them right rope them
and then send them off kick them in the
ass and
pack their lunch and send them send them
off it should be it should be equal
opportunity everywhere that's not though
right when when it's a woman they look
at it like she's just
she's doing her thing she's having a
good time but a man it's like
he's abusing his power that leonardo has
power over those young ladies
i figure like if you're if you're you
know leo or bieber or any of those like
young
like you know like like this is like
what you
part of coming of age yes figuring is
figuring out what you
want in life and you know when you do
that you're going to do weird [ __ ] good
[ __ ] bad [ __ ]
well that's you know whenever every
would if anybody would try to judge
someone like that like
bieber in particular right because he
was really really young when he got
famous i mean it's insane
and you know that whole thing that that
theory that at whatever
however old you are when you get famous
that that like freezes you in carbonite
emotionally and and and intellectually
well that makes sense with child stars
right
anybody yes but anyway it's also that
thing of like
if you ever notice that um before
like you get famous the people who were
famous
to you then
fast forward 100 years or whatever and
like maybe they haven't done
as much and you have but when you meet
them you think they're the most famous
crazy successful person it's the same
yeah it's the same
type of thing if i were to meet you know
dr smith from lost in space
i'd be like no [ __ ] way
doctors do you know what i mean so it's
it's funny how
time i met lee majors i was that's what
i'm saying i was like it's a six million
dollar man
i can't believe it he's real right yeah
yeah yeah cheech and chong when i met
those guys i was like i can't believe
they're real
can't believe i'm meeting them yeah you
get you get frozen in your
your own your own perspective well when
you get older and you become famous
when very few people can have this
conversation right but when you get
famous and you meet famous people
to me it's still weird like when i met
you today i was like oh hello roblo
i've seen you in movies but i'm more
normal with it than when i was young
when i was young and i would meet like i
remember the first time i was on the set
of news radio and i met phil hartman
i was so weirded out i was like he's
right there this is great because i
hadn't met a lot of famous people back
then only like
a small handful
[Applause]